so as i was making that video yesterday
about the various captain britney corps
members and peggy carter what if all
that kind of stuff
something occurred to me and i started
thinking about that moment where i
talked about how based on what a mortise
told us everybody thinks the kang war
was just kang vs kang
but what did amortis say amortis told us
that somewhere along the line
there was the multiverse an infinite
number of universes
stacked on top of each other and the
first version of himself to realize that
was some alternate reality version of
kang
that lived in the 31st century and that
as they started exploring the multiverse
they started working together so with
each new universe that was discovered
that king most likely joined the various
council of kings if we want to call it
that
and they explored the multiverse
together but along the line
some of those kings realized that
instead of sharing resources and
technology
they would just conquer it and so this
led to the giant multiversal war that
we're aware of
but i still stand by the idea it doesn't
make any sense that you would just have
kangs fighting each other and that would
somehow lead to the collapse of the
multiverse
specifically because of the fact that
kings focus on time travel
it's not as though every version of kane
the conqueror or any version of kane the
conqueror
has the ability to manipulate reality on
a universal scale
or even a multiversal scale these are
not guys with the power of the molecule
man owen reese who can just
restructure the multiverse as he wishes
to make it into whatever he wants it to
be instead
their focus is time travel and what we
know with time travel from the marvel
cinematic universe is that
when you use it you create alternate
realities so worst case scenario
these kangs start using time travel to
create other universes
potentially spawning more evil versions
of themselves but certainly not doing
anything that would lead to the total
destruction of the entire multiverse
if they're all fighting each other so it
stands to reason that this king war
was much bigger than we originally
thought it was
that instead of it just being king vs
kang it's these kings
with huge armies it's these kings where
you have like
variant versions of the avengers
fighting variant versions of the
avengers now
on the surface that doesn't seem very
threatening right
like an incredible hulk fighting an
incredible hulk okay they fight each
other to a stalemate but with an
infinite number of universes come an
infinite number of possibilities meaning
that in one of those universes
it's an incredible hulk who was bitten
by a radioactive spider
and now it's an incredible hulk with the
power of spider-man that kind of
possibility exists out there in the
multiverse but the question still has to
be asked
what led to the destruction of the
multiverse in the first place
i think it's the scarlet witch and i
think the ancient one had something to
do with it
let's talk about a guy called the
dweller in darkness because this will
make a whole lot more sense in terms of
unifying all these things
so a lot of you guys have heard of a guy
named galactus originally his name was
gallon and in the university came from
his universe was collapsing he didn't
know why but in the twilight of that
universe's life
he merged with that universe's sentience
and then was reborn into the new
universe
as galactus dump that's all it really
was in the 1990s marvel released a comic
called adventures of the x-men it was
actually a line of comics spanning some
number of issues
but one of the things that it did was
tie into the origin of galactus
by introducing a guy named the dweller
in darkness the whole idea behind this
is that the dweller in darkness is what
you call a fearlord
imagine somebody like mephisto but
instead of being a demon it actually
just feeds on fear
and that was a dweller in darkness what
the dweller and darkness wanted to do
was basically fracture something called
the emcron crystal which was
really this giant hallway of doors for
the multiverse the important thing here
is that
with the m chron crystal fractured the
multiverse started getting sucked in
and that's what led to the collapse of
gallons universe along with
basically every other universe in
existence eventually the dweller in
darkness was defeated but there was no
way to stop the multiversal collapse
and so what marvel did is they expanded
that and they said what actually
happened
is that when galactus merged with the
sentience of the universe
he actually merged with the sentience of
the multiverse hence why every
universe and the new multiverse has a
version of galactus why does that matter
because if you take that concept not
necessarily verbatim but you apply it to
the mcu
what this tells us is that there had to
be a singular being out there that had a
level of power that was so extreme
that it was a danger to the entirety of
the multiverse
and that while it wouldn't be somebody
like the dweller in darkness it could
certainly be the scarlet witch
the scarlet witch as it's been stated to
us is more powerful than the sorcerer
supreme
we'll talk about the controversies and
the problem with that here in a second
but we also know based on one division
that presumably wanda
has left and gone into the multiverse we
know she'll be a part of doctor strange
too multiverse and madness
and the idea is that she's the main
villain there which means she's a person
on a multiversal level of power if
that's the case and it stands to reason
that agatha harkness and all those guys
know about the prophecy of the scarlet
witch
and her return as being something that
will basically lead to
another multiversal war or at least be a
part of the multiversal war
because that's how it played out
originally with kang that one of those
versions of kang
got his hands on the scarlet witch
presumably used her
to literally start going through and
wiping out whole other universes
now this begs the question why is this
universe with a mortise still around
right was the the whole sacred timeline
really reformed out of the remnants of
the multiverse
no i don't think so so the whole thing
behind this is that i think of mortis
that version of jonathan majors that we
saw at the end of loki
this whole timeline that we've seen in
the marvel cinematic universe that's his
timeline that he was able to keep his
timeline protected he was able to keep
it safe
and the reason why was using the power
of the ancient one see one of the things
that's kind of funny about this is that
if you look at the ancient one in the
original doctor strange film
the ancient one talks to stephen strange
about the multiverse but i have a very
hard time believing that the ancient one
with all of her vaulted power
and all of her experience transferring
and getting involved in all these
different dimensional calamities and
all that kind of stuff doesn't know
about the tva
and doesn't know about immortus i have a
very hard time believing that
i think what actually happened here is
that in this multiversal war that took
place with all these kings
the ancient one was still around we
don't know how old she is we just know
she's very old
quite literally doctor strange asked
beer and mordo how old is the ancient
one and he says
we don't know we just know that she's
ancient but the cool thing is that if
you look at that it's entirely possible
that during this multiversal war
that maybe every other universe had its
own version of the ancient one who knows
who cares
but this version of the ancient one
played by tilda swinton worked with
immortus to preserve the universe
to save it from the power of the scarlet
witch how can the ancient one do that
if the power of the scarlet witch
transcends the power of the sorcerer
supreme
here's a problem with the prophecy or
the idea that i get the hardness
throughout there
and talking about the power of the
sorcerer supreme versus the power of the
scarlet witch
her knowledge comes from the darkhold
but we don't know when the darkhold was
written we don't know how old it is
we don't know if it's one of these
instances where at that particular point
in time
the power of the sorcerer supreme was
limited in comparison to the power of
the ancient one maybe the ancient one's
power
grew as time went on we know that there
were sorcerer supremes before her
and so even if it wasn't necessarily the
ancient one that worked with immortus
it's entirely possible one of the
sorcerer supremes did
and that knowledge was passed down from
sorcerer supreme to sorcerer supreme
and that when stephen strange was told
about the multiverse by the ancient one
she was lying her ass off that she
wasn't saying that there's an actual
multiverse i mean she was there's an
infinite number of universes so on and
so forth
but she lied to him she showed him
dimensions but didn't actually show him
universes why
because a multiverse doesn't exist the
multiverse didn't exist the multiverse
hasn't existed for a long time
and are you really gonna trust that
knowledge with a guy that you met five
minutes beforehand
so it kind of makes sense so the ancient
one would be lying to steven strange
he would eventually figure it out over
time and he would discover that hey like
the tva exists because there was a kang
war
and that it being like the scarlet witch
from some far-flung universe and
some however many you know years ago
ended up helping this king
conquer all of existence so hey it's in
our best interest to keep this quiet
like it's it makes sense that that's the
case and so if you look at it kind of
consolidating
all of this together right the marvel
cinematic universe timeline
exists in its current form because some
kings from an alternate reality banded
together decided they wanted to conquer
the universe
one of those kings got their hands on
the scarlet witch sort of wiping out all
these different alternate realities
and that whatever sorcerer supreme
existed in the main marvel universe at
the time worked alongside the marvel
cinematic universe's version of kang
also known as immortus to preserve the
universe and to keep it safe and
isolated away
so that when the multiversal war was
going on between all these kings
they were doing what amounted to
standing on a hillside and watching it
all unfold
and instead their universe was safe it
was kept hidden away from everything
so that when the multiverse collapsed
theirs was the only one left and the
bargain they struck was
no one's going to know the multiverse
actually doesn't exist
anybody out there who ever asks any
questions is going to be told that it
does
any source or supreme that comes after
you you will tell them the multiverse
exists how are they going to know the
difference
and then in turn they will fulfill their
role as a sorcerer supreme they'll learn
the truth about why the multiverse
doesn't exist
and they'll keep it secret for the
greater good i is a mortise will stay at
the end of time
and i will form the tva to make sure
that no other realities come into
existence so we don't have to worry
about a repeat of this tang war
i think the whole thing was huge and i
think it was literally a bargain that
was struck
between whoever the sorcerer supreme was
and and cain the conqueror immortus
i think that's what happened and i love
that idea i love the idea that the k war
was just
colossal right whole realities i mean
imagine that
variants of the avengers fighting
variants of the avengers
evil avengers avengers who were good but
they have to do it anyway otherwise
they're going to be wiped out by that
version of kang
people who are serving these different
variants of kang all of which
are variants of characters that we
already know iron man
fighting iron man captain america's
fighting captain americas
the captain britain corps is involved
all that kind of stuff i think
it's huge and i think as time goes on
we're going to find out that there is a
lot happening when it came to that kang
war
as it was told to us by immortus was
just focusing on kangs i think doctor
strange 2 is going to invoke a lot of
that stuff
i think it's going to show us a lot of
crazy things but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments
section i'm really curious what your
all's thoughts are on this it was kind
of a spur-of-the-moment theory
admittedly i haven't given it a whole
lot of thought i probably should have
but honestly i just like making videos
where i just throw theories out there
and just see what sticks but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section if you love it you hate it
punch holes in it thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace